Hi Sam thank you so much for joining me
today tell me a little bit about your
chess upbringing well I didn't have much
of a chess upbring I took my first chess
class with the Berkeley chess school
after school program when I was in
fourth grade I was 9 years old I didn't
play a tournament until I was 11 and uh
growing up in California that was
probably one of the best places in
America to grow up but American chess
was really desolate at the time there's
a reason that you know only me and
Hikaru from that generation uh really
blossomed into top players until the
next Generation came along with like Ray
and Jeffrey and Sam Sean uh but growing
up in America there really were very few
opportunities uh but I'm delighted that
that has changed a lot recently uh
because it's something I really
dedicated my life to and I wasn't able
to do that until I was an adult I know a
lot of people especially those who came
who grew up in other countries other
continents uh were able to do chess
full-time from the time they were 10 or
whatever that was not me I mean I went
through the full American K12 education
system got a University degree uh but
chess always was what motivated me the
most it was what I was most pass passate
about I worked really really hard and
very proud of how far I've come do you
have a book that has influenced you the
most as you growing up uh there have
been so many uh books that have had a
positive impact on me uh there was
certainly all of The Grandmaster uh
preparation series The repertoire ones
with quality chess the first one with
Boris aook convinced me to start playing
D4 when IID played E4 my whole life and
uh that sort of turned me around in a
lot of good ways um but if you made me
pick one book that I think
uh had the biggest impact on me was
practical chess defense and that was for
two reasons one because I think it's a
really good book and two because uh uh I
it inspired me to work with yakob ogard
the author and he's been my coach ever
since and um you know when I won the
Sanford Fellowship in uh this was 2014
uh and I had money at my disposal for
the first time in my life I was you know
2600 as an adult I had made it there
that far but I was sort of stuck and I
needed a coach at that point and hiring
yakob came and the rest is history and I
know he's convinced you or maybe you two
have worked together and you've become
an author as well you recently have
published a new book can you tell me a
little bit about your career as an
author as well yeah so basically my top
priority by far is trying to be the best
chess player I can be and a lot of my
peers you know 2700 Club they take one
look at me like why are you writing so
many books creating so much content and
the answer is quite simple is I write
about stuff that I want to improve
myself uh so for example my most recent
book theoretical Rook end Games took
three and years to write it's finally
it's going to be released October 18th I
have some Advanced copies here uh but it
was three and a half years of studying
complex Rook hand games I mean yeah I
get that maybe putting them into words
not is not like 100% the most useful use
of my time for training but I learned so
much writing this book and I'm just
looking at myself as a I I have plenty
of examples of my own games in this book
when I was 2700 and just miss playing
Rook end games and now hopefully that
will happen less often so every single
project I've ever taken on for both for
Quality chess and for chessable has been
done with the same stated goal in mind
to make me a better chess players for
completely selfish reasons and uh if the
readers want to come along for the ride
they're welcome to and funnily enough
this model has been extremely successful
for the books everyone really loves them
uh I'm just doing my own training and
inviting people to join yeah I've seen a
lot of your books you're also writing um
and you've created courses on chessable
and on chessable you're mostly known for
your
openings uh courses
which one would you say is uh the most
uh important to study or is it all three
parts of the game uh well I mean you
can't be a complete chest player without
being good at All Phases of the game if
I were to make an analogy that I quite
like is if you can run really fast uh
control the ball really well with your
feet pass really well shoot really well
dribble really well steal really well
and you can't stop the ball with your
hands to save your life that's fine
don't be a goalkeeper in ch if you're
really good at openings you're well
prepared you've analyzed them deep into
the Early Middle game you have very good
tactical vision for quick little tricks
good positional feel for your pieces you
know have good knowledge of technical
end games but you can't calculate to
save your life you've got a problem and
so I think to sort of isolate one part
of Chess or some parts of Chess is more
important than others is just not true
it's not a good idea and you have to be
a complete player capable of playing All
Phases of the game in order to play at a
high level when you were young uh you've
often mentioned uh on your social media
that Gary Kasparov was one of your
Heroes uh was he the one who influence
to the most as um as a world champion
yes of course Gary Kasparov was my
earliest hero one of the biggest reasons
was just that I met him I mean for what
it's worth I know this sounds ridiculous
when you look at the world today I never
met a Grandmaster until I was 15 I never
played with one until I was 16 you know
this I did not have a quick development
and I did not have opportunities to play
with strong players and travel and stuff
like that I mean I I had the opportunity
to play with a bunch of 2200s starting
very very young in San Francisco which
I'm extremely grateful for I know at
least at the time that was a lot more
than a lot of other people had
especially in this country uh but I
didn't have an opportunity to like
really meet with strong players and I
didn't get how good Grand Masters and
top Grand Masters and you know super
Elite world champions could be and when
I got to meet Gary kaspar for a weekend
uh along with a bunch of other young
American Juniors and he just completely
opened my eyes to the level of
Excellence that chess players can strive
for and uh it inspired me and laid the
foundation for who I am today and he
will always be my biggest hero and I'm
sure you felt really great when you had
the opportunity to win against him um
earlier a few months ago actually or
maybe a month ago in here in St Louis in
9lx yeah so I've played with Kasparov
twice uh both games were sort of
blowouts the first one he completely
crushed me the second game maybe crushed
as the wrong word but it was a pretty
smooth Victory on my part so uh just
playing with him is is a huge honor I
mean chess 9lx is a lot of fun it's it's
great but it's not super serious it's
not rated it's sort of an exhibition
event so I didn't care so much about the
results obviously I was very proud to
have beaten him in one of the two games
we played but uh really just playing
with Gary is a tremendous honor because
he doesn't play classical chess anymore
and that's just what you can do um but
yeah it was one of the proudest moments
of my life when I beat him I mean it
says a lot that this guy's 60 years old
18 years retired and beating him in an
exhibition game is one of the proudest
moments of my life all the same that's
how good he was okay and uh I was
wondering about this competition you
have to come back from
rapid chess Blitz events that you had to
play to classical chess what did you do
specifically to prepare for this event
well I played some longer training games
which hopefully helps I haven't been
able to play much classical events this
year there haven't been that many
classical events and I wasn't invited to
very manyy either which was tough uh but
classical chess is certainly what I
specialize in the most it's what I'm
best at I've dedicated my training plan
in the last you know my entire adult
life towards becoming the best classical
chest player I can be and as a result
for the most part I've lagg behind in
Rapid and Blitz uh which I still view as
less important overall it's not been
that terrible obviously like in 960
rapid I made plus three this time last
time in 960 I made plus two and I made
plus one in the rapid section of the St
Louis rapid and Blitz last year so I
mean I I can play rapid when I need to
but classical is what I've worked the
most at it's been a really rough year
for me in a lot of ways but I'm I'm
feeling motivated and energized and I'm
ready to turn around now well thank you
very much Sam looking forward to reading
your book and good luck in this
competition
[Music]